hello everyone uh welcome to pi data
global 2021 my name is floren russell
i'm very proud to share this session
please join me in welcoming ezan tonti
to tony sorry azanto tony
he'd be talking about odo super
computing like performance and scale for
python and pandas
essen is an entrepreneur computer
science researcher and software engineer
working on democratization of high
performance computing for data analytics
ainml azan received his phd in computer
science from the university in illinois
at urban campaign
working on various aspects of hpc and
parallel computing he then worked as a
research scientist at intel labs and
carnegie mellon university focusing on
programming systems to address the gap
between programmer productivity and
computer performance sn drives bodo's
mission to democrat democrats hpc for
data science with a belief that it
should not remain a best bastion of
select few experts
and as more moore's laws begins to slow
it is essence vision to parallel to
apply parallel computing principles to
maintain
computing's evolution so
over to you and
enjoy the talk
thank you florian
excited to be here and introduce board
of the pi data community ames santa tony
co-founder and city of bordeaux as
florian mentioned we are a new platform
for big data processing applications
that bring simplicity of python and
performance of hpc together at the same
time using a new inferential compiler
technology that i will explain in a
minute
so the problem we are addressing is the
fact that in
various organizations development of
data applications
such as machine learning happens in
python
using
libraries such as pandas but it's
typically on local files and laptops
but
to scale the code to production
the python code is typically written in
some other language sometimes java
scholastic plus plus or python apis on
top of a java system and with a system
such as spark to scale to production
even then
things like spark are far from hpc
performance high performance completed
performance and have a lot of
inefficiencies so extremely difficult to
scale to production and even then there
are a lot of inefficiencies
bordeaux is a new platform that can
scale the same python code to production
without rewriting it so
border platform is responsible for
providing high performance connectors
automatic parallelization of the code to
scale and large number of cores
end-to-end optimization of the code
providing the right primitive such as
joint and so on high performance way
under the hood and integrating with
various systems out there so this is the
border platform at a very high level and
we will go to
various details in this talk
but to get us started to show how the
code looks like this code is
from
one of our
partners nasdaq and it's uh loading a
large data set arcade data set from
storage and in that case it was a hadoop
storage
filtering the data frame using some
regular expression they were interested
in transaction of a certain uh in
certain sessions in the exchange and
calling described which gives a lot of
statistics
so for this python code portal handles
all of these operations the same apis as
pandas and all the user needs to do is
add this portal that jit decorator so
border engine is just a python package
conda installed bordeaux
as you can see and you can launch this
program on any number of cores in this
case they use 224
with mpi exec just you would do on any
high performance computing system but
this can be done on any cl any
underlying infrastructure hadoop cluster
cloud
aws azure gcp doesn't matter and it can
be notebooks as i will demo as well so
native python apis no new pandas like
api layers
more capabilities than something like
spark because in spark you don't have
quantile calculation for example because
quantiles don't fit the map reduce
parallel pattern and you get
hpc performance and scalability so auto
under the hose uses obviously number for
a lot of a python developer number is a
familiar tool for jit compilation but
also bordeaux supports mpi which is
standard for
parallel computing and super computing
applications
so our platform as i mentioned can be
installed can be used on any
infrastructure on-premises cloud
anywhere and we support open source api
expanders numpy cited learn because we
are a compiler solution we don't need to
expose new apis and border can be used
on any storage we're completely storage
agnostic
csv files on s3 part parquet files
snowflake data warehouse hadoop it
doesn't matter and you can
integrate with border with any
visualization tool
out there
so
here's
a quick benchmark to show you how it
works uh at a high level how it compares
to
something like spark uh one of our
customers is a big fortune terror 10
tech company and
they use tpcx peakbench tpc is
an organization industrial standard
organization for benchmarking big data
systems and databases and for decades
the tpc benchmarks have been standard
for benchmarking so our customer took
this benchmark on a large aws cluster
with
125 instances
with a total of
4500 cores so 4500 cores a large cluster
and they ran this benchmark on scale
factor 40 000 which in tpc terminology
means the total data set in memory is
probably around 40 terabytes so they
optimize the spark
solution which they use emr solution of
aws
manually with the java
tuning and parameters
but even after all these optimizations
bordeaux without tuning was over 20
times faster than spark on this large
cluster so this shows that bodo is very
good for use cases such as etl data prep
feature engineering and these sort of
applications that these benchmarks
represent
but taking a step back
the problem for scaling code goes back
to the old
problem of simplicity performance gap
that has been
an open computer science problem
for for several decades so on one
extreme you have high level scripting
code
used to be matlab or now it's mostly
python
the favorite of programmers so scripting
codes are very simple to use high-level
apis such as pandas but they are slow
and single core they don't scale
natively on the other extreme is
high-performance computing code
some advanced universities or national
laboratories of various uh countries
such as the united states
there are hpc experts that write mpi
code very low level mpi fortran c plus
class and these codes scale to hundreds
of thousands of cores sometimes millions
but they are extremely difficult to
write sometimes they take years so
there is a huge gap between simplicity
and performance in programming
and that's what we tackle
the solution to this problem would be
having a compiler that can automatically
take the simple code and generate the
fast code for you and essentially
automate the process of
an hpc expert but this is a very
difficult problem and has never been
solved before and that's what we have
solved for the first time we believe so
a regular compiler just translates your
code that's a c code
into a sequential binary
but bordeaux's inferential compiler
takes the human readable code in this
case python analyzes the
code structure
to understand its operations and the
algorithm
optimizes the operations as much as
possible and translates the code into a
fully parallel execution
binary and it's as if an hp hbc expert
wrote the code for you but it happens in
real time and transparently so that's
the right solution we believe for
scaling code
and this is the result of uh many years
of research
and development at uh you know intel
labs founding medium university where i
was and now at podo
so it's not an easy problem to solve but
because bordeaux didn't exist
the
industry went a different route things
like spark task and raid so the way
other systems work is that the python
code is rewritten in terms of some other
apis
so task apis pandas like apis in das or
ray moden or pi spark
if you will so the code is written in
terms of these apis and
it runs on top of this
library and the way it's
executed is that the
program starts on the driver program so
the program is actually sequential but
when the high level apis are called
the
library breaks up the computation into
tasks goes across the cluster run those
runs those tasks and comes back the
driver we call this waves of tiny tasks
model and the problem is that these
tasks
have a lot of overhead to be scheduled
and sent to the cluster all the data
that they need
and come back and managing all these
tasks dependencies and task graphs
so a very high overhead the suita system
approach and we have a paper about this
if you will i'd like more details
the way bordeaux bother works is that
the python code is compiled to a native
parallel binary with mti as if an htc
expert would write the code and runs on
bare metal and the program is actually
paralyzed there is no driver running the
code all the cores are running the code
they have their own chunk of the data
and they know what to do with what to do
with their data they know how to
communicate and how to execute
efficiently they are not going to a
centralized driver or master and uh it's
the mpi model and the so-called single
program multiple data model
that has been the standard of parallel
computing
for decades so we believe bodo provides
a true parallel or architecture solution
and this is the scientifically correct
way to do parallel computing for
data workloads that we are targeting and
task scheduling is not the right way
so at a very high level there are two
dimensions simplicity and performance
for data systems and big data systems
and we provide simplicity of python and
performance of hpc and we believe we are
far away from other solutions in this
space
and i will show benchmarks and
use cases and examples to to demonstrate
so based on these results
we believe python should be used for
hard data engineering problems python
shouldn't be a prototyping language and
all the enterprises big companies
writing the code to java or c plus plus
or scala out of python with bordeaux the
code can stay in python and python can
be faster than java and we are often
significantly faster so for difficult
problems like etl data transformations
data cleaning data prep on terabyte or
petabyte data sets for feature
engineering that's where
where bodo shines
so
for data engineering the first step is
always scalable io how do you load this
multi-terabyte data set into memory
efficiently
with bordeaux the apis are
standard pandas apis so the code looks
like pandas you can say load this park a
data set which could be
like a directory of a lot of pieces or
even csv could be directory of a lot of
pieces or loads from snowflake or the
state of warehouse
using pandas that read sequel and
portal is responsible for loading the
data and different chunks on different
cores efficiently so you don't have to
worry about that
to show you an example of this i think
loading from snowflake is a challenging
operation or any sql system
that we solved recently and we just
released the new bordeaux version for it
it's challenging to load from sql based
systems because if you have a large
cluster of ten thousand cores
uh one approach would be to send ten
thousand queries to the data warehouse
to load different chunks and we have
found that this overwhelms even the most
scalable systems such as snowflake so
snowflake released a new distributed
fetch connector
that we have been working with them
in terms of design and implementation
and this new connector allows you to
load the data in batches with just a
single query so one of the cores sends a
query and gets a handle to these batches
of arrow pieces
and the different processors load their
own batch or their own piece out of
those batches and this is a much more
scalable and efficient way to load load
data from snowflake and we
tried a few use cases where snowflake
was doing some of the data load itself
with minimal computation versus border
loading the data using this connector
and in the data kind of the table is
warm in snowflake it has a lot of
caching capabilities we are essentially
equivalent to snowflake in terms of
loading the data
out of the snowflake storage layer which
is very exciting to see
in
in such a difficult problem
so what are the limitations of bordeaux
i think
a lot of developers in the audience know
about number and some of the limitations
of compilation approach
the problem is that python is not
a hundred percent compilable all the
time so there are cases where you can't
assign data types so the most important
thing is data types and type stability
so
some cases where compilation is not
possible on the left side we have this
example of using a flag you can assign
different types to a variable
and
this would result in an error because
the compiler can't
assign a data type to this variable
doesn't know if it's integer or a numpy
array so that's one case and in python
you can do a lot of crazy things such as
you know a function is a variable and
you can you know change the function
variable and just call it it's a
callable object
but the compiler can't resolve the
function and can't do its job
but please don't do that these are not
good program practices in a lot of cases
so
the code has to be clean for the
compiler to understand it at a high
level and be able to
figure out the data types but uh the
data engineers and developers who are
familiar with things like python or
family are with the type language uh i
think they should be able to pick up
bodo
quickly
but how does bordeaux compare to other
systems out there there are just so many
different things coming out on a daily
basis that there is a lot of confusion
in this area and
there are a lot of claims of various by
various companies and projects in terms
of speed and scale
and uh unfortunately i found that a lot
of these claims don't have evidence or
they have some overly simplistic
benchmarks that are just just a single
join or single group i that doesn't tell
you too much about the capabilities of
the system so what we are proposing is
just using standard benchmarks that have
been used for data systems for decades
and you know it shows what we are
targeting we are targeting large data
big data data engineering etl those sort
of workloads tpc benchmarks have been
around forever in particular tpch
benchmarks have been used for a long
time and they are not too complicated
you can actually look at them and after
a few minutes understand what they are
doing so what we did was that we
translated these queries from sql to
python and it's open source you can
look at it and uh
we
wrote versions for das gray other
systems and compared performance and we
are obviously biased and we are not task
experts or spark experts or ray experts
but this is a starting point i think
this is much better than not having any
benchmarks and we invite everybody to
look at what we did take the code run it
yourself let us know what we could do
better for these benchmarks but these
are our benchmarks and this is the way
we benchmark so you know you can you can
look at the sql code and python code i
prefer the python version but it's
subjective some people like sql a lot a
lot more i don't know um
so comparison to spark i think spark is
the closest solution to bordeaux for big
data
we took tpch with a scale factor 1000
which would be
around a terabyte
of data in memory and use the 16 node
cluster which has
576 physical cores um not virtual cores
you know typically there are there's one
physical core pair two virtual cores and
there's a cloud infrastructure
instances and a total of three terabytes
and these instances have good networking
and a fast networking option on aws
called efa elastic fabric adapter where
processes can essentially different
cores can write into each other's memory
direct you don't even need to go through
tcp and the network for doing that it's
much faster than regular networking so
very interesting capability on aws for
high performance computing so
for spark i have three examples here but
across the queries photo was uh average
of 23 times fast actually median up 23
times faster up to 65 times and these
kind of numbers essentially mean
over 90
savings on infrastructure cost
for example if you are paying 100 000 to
aws you would be paying just 10 000. so
a big difference in infrastructure costs
so this is pretty exciting i think to be
orders of magnitude faster than spark
but just python not java or scala so we
compared versus tasks task is not built
for these kind of big data problems etl
feature engineering uh those kind of
machine learning data processing things
i think it's better suited for
scientific computing where you have
completely independent tasks
because communication is difficult in
the ask
but what was surprising was that das
couldn't even load the terabyte data set
on this three terabyte memory cluster
and it was running out of memory so we
scaled back back the data set size to
just 100 gigabyte which is a fraction of
the available memory but that's what das
could handle
and for these type of things we found
das not to be suitable at all order was
150 times faster
on average you can see the numbers you
know 88 seconds versus half a second and
there's there were some cases query 21
task
was hanging and we had to actually
search on google to ask hangs what to do
and we saw a bunch of uh
results so this is seems to be normal
but for something that essentially hangs
bordeaux solves the problem in under a
second
so there's a huge difference and we
don't think um
das has a long way to go to catch up to
spark and
i don't think task is capable of hp
capable of hpc with mpi in this current
design
we try to compare to ray with the mod in
package they have for data processing
but we couldn't load anything more than
10 gigabyte to memory so we may be doing
something wrong
it may need some configuration we will
publish the exact details of versions
and whatever we did so please help us
how to
to see how we can run something but in
general tas was originally built for
reinforcement learning
and for data engineering and big data
workloads
seems like it's not ready but what i
wanted to mention is that task
scheduling systems
have
limitations compared to hvc systems and
there are certain overheads that cannot
be avoided so we believe the ceiling for
their performance uh is spark which took
years of development to kind of work
around the disputed system issues uh but
still you know bothers faster than spark
we think uh
an mpi based hpc solution is the best
for data processing
uh for uh big big applications
so just uh
a quick
benchmark for one of our customers
before i show a quick demo
they were running uh spark for their
data pipeline
sorry to interrupt we have five more
minutes so
just to let you know if you want to
switch up and also take questions you
have five more minutes sure definitely
so for this use case a real machine
learning data pipeline we're over 12
times faster and a huge saving for the
their azure bill and they can
do real-time machine learning and
analytics for their business units now
uh a real kind of retail customer um so
with that i would like to show you a
quick demo on the border cloud platform
you can install bordeaux from condo on
your laptop a free version and you can
get on our managed cloud service and
here you can create clusters in your own
aws account
attach notebooks to it i already have a
cluster of four workers each with eight
physical cores so 32 total cores
uh i'll open the notebook
and i'll show you a quick example where
i
generated some random data or just some
date
time just a single column
and in regular python doing a transform
with apply just writing custom code that
pandas can't just uh call the canned
like c library or psython library these
sort of things really need compilation
so in pandas this takes 21 minutes i
can't run it right now we don't have
time but with bodo
just adding this g decorator auto
understands all of these apis you can
see what apis we support in our
documentation
so you add the border jit decorator and
bordeaux compiles this
apply function to native code
with llvm in the background and takes
five seconds
so 20 minutes to five seconds and then
you add this px magic in
jupiter
and using ipi parallel it came down to
0.15
all the way from the 20 minutes that was
python so huge improvements with
vodaford this type of difficult data
transformation and
all the uh data processing uh things
like join and
group by group by with user defined
functions all of these things are
supported in bordeaux so you can
use sql we actually have a sql solution
as well or just python for all these
difficult tasks with that uh thank you
very much i would be happy to answer
questions excellent thank you so much
for the for the great talk um i think
the first questions
would be from i think we already
answered that around limitations uh so
i'll jump to the second one which is
from adam kinsey um so adam is asking if
bordeaux is a uh if border is not driver
execute a driver executor how does it
handle processes that are fundamentally
non-parallel or which have sequential
dependencies
so
data processing
operations like join and
group by and things like that they all
have parallel semantics and bordeaux
analyzes the code the whole program and
figures out what operations can be
paralyzed what operations cannot be
paralyzed if something can be paralyzed
a bordeaux is able to paralyze that but
some data structures shouldn't be
paralyzed so there are dependencies bodo
automatically figures it out and
replicates those data structures
if
it's not possible there's a problem in
the program bodo will
let you know for sure right
and you have to change something in the
program voldo doesn't have any
limitation compared to those primary
computers those driver executor systems
are essentially approximating what
bordeaux is doing so they are not doing
something extra for these type of
workloads
excellent thank you we have another
question from alex alex is asking uh
seems like odo is commercial besides a
community license why not open source it
what are the advantages disadvantages
for going commercial for this type of
project
so
we do use open source and if you are
interested in contributing to this
technology please contribute to number
i'm a developer of number as well we are
always looking for contributors and uh
contribute to mpi or
arrow and these kind of uh open source
projects or ipython parallel we are
sponsoring archive park unparalleled so
we are sponsoring open source uh where
possible but we keep something close
source the
core of the engine uh because uh aws
well if we don't do that we can't make
money
and we have seen a lot of problems with
uh you know having the core of your
system open source uh so uh the business
model doesn't work if you know a
business model that
would let us compete with aws let me
know and we will open source whatever we
can
excellent that sounds like a good
promise well uh in terms of
yeah i just wanted to mention we have a
community edition on eight cores on your
laptop for free free trial on our
platform and let us know what you think
thank you very much
excellent thank you again so much for
the great presentation uh and thank you
everybody who asked questions thank you
very much i appreciate it bye
you